December of 2019 is going to be a
fateful time for Netflix with Disney
Plus having gone live in the middle of
November here are a few titles jumping
to Disney in December plus a few more
leaving Netflix not owned by the house
of mouse if you haven't seen this
particular Marvel Cinematic Universe
offering yet now's as good a time as any
the third installment of the Thor series
is one of the higher rated and more
widely acclaimed installments in the
entire MCU even those who typically
don't get into superhero films tend to
make an exception for this one with its
expert blend of action parts and humor
want to use a big wooden fork you're not
really useful unless you're fighting off
three vampires that were huddled
together as with all MCU films it does
help to have seen a few others before
diving into Ragnarok but the film is a
fairly well contained story that outside
context only enhances rather than being
a necessity
directed by Taika Waititi Ragnarok sees
the God of Thunder learning some new and
uncomfortable hidden truths about
Asgardian history and his father Odin a
conflict with a new and powerful enemy
sends Thor to the secret world of Sekar
ruled over by the Grandmaster and home
to his ruthless gladiator games along
with old friends and new alliances Thor
must survive and find a way to fleece a
card to save his homeland from the
threat of Ragnarok the prophecy that
foretells the destruction of the entire
Asgardian race Thor Ragnarok will be
leaving Netflix on December 4 with a box
office take of 1.3 billion dollars there
aren't many sci-fi fans left who haven't
seen Star Wars the last Jedi at least
once if you somehow missed it this is
probably the last opportunity to stream
it on a third party platform before it
reaches on Disney Plus forever more
writer director Rian Johnson makes a
concerted effort to both enrich Star
Wars lore and to play with expectations
giving fresh perspectives of what we
know about the Jedi and the universe and
which Star Wars exists the force is not
a power you have it's not about lifting
rocks
it's the energy between all things the
last Jedi immediately picks up where the
force awakens left off with Rey
beginning a proper education in the use
of the Force in doing so she'll discover
many truths about the Jedi Luke
Skywalker and his relationship with kylo
Ren meanwhile division begins to Royal
within the resistance and the first
order is on the hunt hoping to destroy
the resistance as High Command at last
desiree begins to realize that nothing
is what it seems how will she go forward
both for her own sake and that of the
resistance Star Wars the last Jedi
leaves Netflix on December 25th seeing
the 1982 feature the Dark Crystal before
it leaves Netflix is of particular
importance if you have watched or want
to get around to watching Netflix's
revival series the Dark Crystal age of
resistance the modern series is set well
before the events of the film and
chronicles the downfall of the world and
near extinction of the species known as
the gelfling the movie may be going away
but not necessarily forever Jim Henson's
Muppet works and characters are owned by
Disney but the Dark Crystal film and its
characters are owned entirely by the Jim
Henson Company which is still an
independent studio the license will
likely be reappointed a future
especially if a second season of the
revival series is Greenland as for the
film the Dark Crystal directed by Jim
Henson and Frank Oz is a high fantasy
story about the planet thraw a world on
the edge of total destruction a thousand
years before the evil vulture like
Skeksis shattered a magic crystal in
order to use it for themselves as a
source of eternal life draws last living
gelflings jan and kira
undertake a quest to find the missing
shard and heal the crystal in hopes of
destroying the Skeksis and returning
thraw to its former thriving and lush
green state the Dark Crystal departs
Netflix on December 31st Schindler's
List likely needs no introduction the
1993 historical drama appeared on
Leonard Maltin slist of the 100 most
important films of the 20th century and
won a small avalanche of awards
including six Oscars directed by Steven
Spielberg the film is an adaptation of
the historical fiction novel Schindler's
Ark while it depicts actual events and
the central characters did exist some of
the narrative lacks firm historical
record and has been filled in with
supposition the film tells the story of
Oskar Schindler a factory owner who
saved over a thousand Jewish people from
death at the hands of the
see regime by trafficking them through
his business Schindler begins as a
faithful Nazi Party member enjoying
status among the SS employing Jews
recruited from the ghetto for cheap
labor when the ghetto was purged however
the violence is so extreme that
Schindler's allegiance is forever
altered afterwards he begins working
with his Jewish business partner in
secret to secure the safety of as many
Jews as possible Schindler's List will
leave Netflix on December 31st wet hot
American summer released in 2001 -
underwhelming reviews and a brutal box
office has developed a reputation as a
nostalgic cult classic in the years
since part of that is due to a talented
cast that's only gone on to huge success
in the intervening years since the
film's release
among them are Christopher Maloney david
Hyde Pierce Janeane Garofalo Paul Rudd
Amy Poehler and many more the film
focuses on the last days of summer camp
at the fictional campfire wood in 1981
or the various kids and camp counselors
fall in love getting to high jinks and
playing talent shows sounds like pretty
well-worn territory the whole thing
feels kind of trite I say we forget it
that how everybody feels well they also
try to save the camp from being crushed
by a piece of NASA's Skylab that happens
to be plummeting through Earth's
atmosphere what hot American summer will
also be departing from Netflix on
December 31st check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
and TV shows are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]